today's video is sponsored by under
lucky stars commemorate a special time
in your life or the life of a loved one
with a personalized star map more on
them in a bit
in this chat of short lifetime we've
covered endless men who made their mark
many became kings emperors leaders of
movements that changed the course of
history but even among this pantheon
it's rare to find men or women who went
one step further who became not just a
human figurehead but the focal point of
an entire religion well in this episode
we're going to meet one such man haile
selassie as a mere mortal he reigned
over the nation of ethiopia for 44
transformative years yet his longest
lasting legacy likely has its roots over
12 000 kilometers away in the jamaica of
the 1930s the rastafari religion
coalesced around the idea that selassie
was not just a powerful man
but literally got today an estimated one
million follows of rastafarianism
subscribe to this belief yet who was the
historical figure at the center of it
all and how did he become this
religion's messiah born in a mudhut
hailey selassie rose through the ranks
of ethiopia's royal family to become its
last emperor as leader he weathered coup
attempts invasion resistance to his
progressive reforms only to at last be
overthrown by his own people powerful
tragic and nuanced this is the life of
haile selassie africa's king of kings
it was july the 23rd 1892 when the boy
who would become highly selassie was
born into a life of both privilege
and poverty poverty because his family
like nearly all 26 million of ethiopia's
inhabitants lived in a simple modern
wattle heart within a vast rural country
still wedded to the feudal system and
privileged because unlike most
ethiopians selassie had the aristocratic
background to escape this life members
of the powerful amhara tribe selassie's
family claimed they could trace their
roots all the way back to emperor melik
the first himself supposedly the child
of king solomon and the queen of sheba
this meant that selassie was also
related to the current emperor menelik
ii and you better believe this conferred
certain advantages as a boy selassie was
educated by french missionaries his
father ras mcconan was governor of harap
speaking of selassie now might be a good
time to mention names although he's gone
down in history as hailey selassie the
future emperor was actually born tafari
mcconan like his father he was elevated
to the title of ras or duke it's from
the fusion of his title and name ras
tafari that rastafarianism gets its name
and while we're on the subject we should
probably also discuss ethiopia if you
paid attention in history class you
might be under the impression that
ethiopia in this era was called absinia
which it was but only by outsiders for
this reason we're just going to refer to
it as ethiopia throughout just as we'll
be calling tafari highly selassie even
though he wouldn't take on that name
until 1930. got it well great so let's
move on with today's story when selassie
was just a teen his father died but
while this doubtless hurt it also took
him closer than ever to the center of
power taken in by the emperor selassie
became part of addis ababa's political
elite eventually becoming promoted all
the way to governor of his dad's old
province it was while working there that
selassie began to truly grasp ethiopia's
problems while the empire was thousands
of years old the nation itself seemed
like it was stuck in the middle ages
dominated by a land-owning ability
ethiopia had few roads few large
buildings no organized health care and
little in the way of government
infrastructure in essence it was a
feudal society and that was worrying
this was the heyday of colonialism when
european powers were gobbling up so much
african real estate that very very few
places hadn't been absorbed into some
empire or another selassie was quick to
define that if ethiopia didn't modernize
it too would become little more than an
exotic outpost to be exploited but what
could he do as a mere governor although
he was related to the emperor selassie
wasn't in line for the throne when
menelik ii died in 1913 it was the
good-looking playboy legiasu who
replaced him
not the orphan selassie as with his
father's death though selassie would
soon manage to turn this latest set back
into an advantage
asusi had an image problem his ancestors
had been muslim in a nation where the
elite were all christian so when he
started making moves to de-secularize
society those same elites didn't see a
serious attempt to improve the lot of
ethiopia's religious minorities but
rather a diabolical plot to make them
all worship allah and stop drinking
their beloved taige as head of the
christian opposition selassie led the
charge in accusing yasu of being an
apostate a traitor and generally just a
giant douchebag when in 1916 iyasu also
started making overtures to world war
one central powers it was the last straw
yasuo was overthrown that september
replaced with melanic's daughter zuditu
but since the idea of female rumor was
almost as bad to these guys as an
islamic emperor it was decided zuditu
needed a region someone who could give
her reign a shot of testosterone
care to guess who they chose in early
1917 selassie was appointed zu ditu's
crown prince and heir apparent and so
began
his unstoppable rise to power
[Music]
in many ways the pairing of selassie and
zoo did two was an odd one while
selassie was aligned with ethiopia's
progressives you do was so conservative
that should make mitch mcconnell look
like a
jowly che guevara yet there was
something both empress and crown prince
had in common they were both capable of
being staggeringly ruthless it was often
said that selassie crept like a mouse
but had the jaws of a lion and those
jaws started snapping shut even before
he became heir apparent in the battle
against yasu's forces selassie was
merciless superior firepower and
executions were deployed to solidify his
grip on power it was brutal
but it worked ethiopia failed to spiral
into the predictable chaos combined with
the destruction of yasu's army in summer
1917 a larger crisis was averted and so
the crown prince was at last free to
pursue his long-desired reforms as the
1920s dawned it was on in ethiopia in
the grip of furious change under
selassie's orders new schools were being
opened designed to educate the children
of the elite along european lines a
professional civil service and
bureaucracy was beginning to be brought
in taking power out of the hands of the
feudal overlords the first moves were
even being made on the abolition of
slavery although it would be decades
before a full-scale ban was implemented
arguably though the most important
changes were in ethiopia's international
relations in 1923 selassie took his
country into the league of nations a
kind of precursor to the u.n with added
uselessness to selassie though the
league's collective security seemed to
guarantee ethiopia's safety from
colonial powers as did his burgeoning
friendship with those same powers in
1924 he became ethiopia's first ruler to
make an international trip traveling
through europe's great capitals and
schmoozing everybody while the stated
reason for buttering up the europeans
was to encourage investment in private
selassi was more direct saying we need
european progress only because we are
surrounded by it in other words keep the
mad colonizers at bay by letting them
invest in ethiopia's booming markets and
in the 1920s those markets were really
booming with coffee selling
spectacularly more money was being freed
up to construct roads and communication
lines while a new class of entrepreneurs
was starting to emerge it was in short a
good era for progress but not everybody
was happy in the palace udu and her
conservative allies were stewing at the
reforms upending their nation from their
perspective selassie's improvements were
more like unforgivable decadence the
beginning of ethiopia's slide into
ignominity so in 1928 they decided to
get rid of him only to find themselves
stepping
right into those lion's jaws the
september 1928 coup was such a failure
that zuditu's limited authority
collapsed in the aftermath she was
forced to proclaim selassie negus or
king but this title would only be a
stepping stone a year and a half after
the coup in the spring of 1930s uditu
was found dead apparently of
complications relating to diabetes with
that selassie's takeover was complete on
november 2nd 1930 the man who had been
born jafari mcconan was crowned
ethiopia's 225th emperor it's at this
point that he took the name haile
selassie meaning might of the trinity
amid a lavish coronation ceremony held
in addis ababa salasi's coronation was
eye-wateringly expensive involving all
manner of spectacular uniforms and
sumptuous decorations although the
european press including the novelist
evelyn war ridiculed it they were
missing the point selassie wanted to
project a vision of ethiopia with as
much pomp and regalia as anything in
europe a state that wasn't a potential
colony but an equal to anywhere where
white men ruled eight months after
taking power he set out his new vision
for this ethiopia in writing the 1931
constitution placed selassie at the
center of everything a paternal ruler
who always knew what was best for his
people and could never be opposed from
now on the king of kings would rule as
an absolute monarch alright so we'll get
back to today's video in just a second
but first quick word from our brand new
video sponsor under lucky stars under
lucky stars make beautiful personalized
star maps that show the unique alignment
of the stars in a place and time chosen
by you this is the original map maker
four stars with a proprietary method of
mapping the stars in the universe
verified by astrophysicists from nasa so
you know you gain the real deal how does
it work well all you have to do is enter
the location date and time of a special
moment in your life that you'd like to
commemorate and unlucky stars can show
you exactly how the sky looked at that
time with a beautiful map printed on
museum quality thick matte art paper
there are more than 15 designs and six
border options to choose from which
means you can create a totally
personalized memento i've got mine right
here it's so big it's so it's a big
reflection of my light
but it's not going to fit in the frame
right but uh
this is a beautiful one it's actually uh
when my wife and i got married so i got
heard that as a gift for valentine's day
you might be thinking well valentine's
day is coming up you haven't got
anything for the loved one in your life
this is a perfect gift it's thoughtful
it's just nice right now you guys can
take advantage of an exclusive 10
discount this valentine's day head to
underluckystars.com forward slash
biographics and use code biographics to
get your loved one a gift they'll never
forget and now back to today's video
the first four years of selassie's reign
could only be called benign despotism
the emperor used his sweeping powers to
drag ethiopia into the modern age
establishing schools building hospitals
and roads and instituting a police force
the result certainly wasn't a democratic
paradise civic participation was almost
non-existent and the idea of anything as
radical as a separation of powers was
little more than a grim joke still for
all selassie might have held the nation
in an iron grip it was at least one
wrapped in a velvet glove his autocratic
tendencies softened by real improvements
the next power to take over the country
by contrast would dispense with softness
entirely on the borders of ethiopia in
eritrea and modern-day somalia a fascist
power was looking to expand benito
mussolini's dream was to establish an
east african empire one that would
include all of selassie's nation of
course as a member of the league of
nations ethiopia was supposedly covered
by its joint security agreement but
mussolini was willing to bet that the
league was even more toothless than it
seemed in this he would be proved
depressingly right tensions started to
climb in november 1934 when ethiopian
and italian troops got caught in a
series of skirmishes near the border of
italian somaliland this was followed by
a massive build-up on the italian side
as il ducey began preparing for war but
selassie still believed membership of
the league would save him rather than
mobilize he asked the league to
adjudicate on the border dispute he was
still waiting for an answer when the
invasion began opening on october the
2nd 1935 the italo-ethiopian war was
short it was grim and it was humiliating
as mussolini publicly declared he was on
a mission to bring progress to this
backwoods nation his troops unleashed
chemical weapons while italian planes
dropped bombs on civilian populations as
one correspondent observed this isn't a
war it isn't even a slaughter it's the
torture of tens of thousands of men
women and children with bombs and poison
gas in the face of such dirty tactics
what hope did the ethiopians have on may
2nd 1936 hailey selassie boarded his
imperial train and was taken away into
exile three days later addis ababa fell
as ethiopia crumbled some of the italian
commanders suggested that they bomb
selassie's train but mussolini demured
with a victory so complete the fascist
leader could afford to be magnanimous
seven months after they first crossed
the border the italians had triumphed
one of the only african states to avoid
being colonized was now absorbed into
the colony of italian east africa yet
selassie still clung to the hope that
help might be coming on the 20th of june
150 centimeter tall that's five foot
four emperor stood at a podium before
the league of nations in geneva as
fascist observers booed he made a
dignified speech laying out why the
league needed to act how italy had
broken international law the grave
consequence of inaction famously he
ended with the prophetic phrase it is us
today it will be you tomorrow at the end
of selassie's speech the delegates
applauded then they voted to take no
action while the most powerful nations
france and britain cut separate deals
with mussolini and so the most iconic
moment in selassie's life ended not with
diplomatic triumph
but with the penniless emperor exiled to
the british city of bath unable to even
afford new books to read but of course
this wasn't the end of haile selassie
just over four years after his league of
nations speech italy invaded the
protectorate of british somaliland
bringing world war ii to east africa
sadly for alduce it was the dumbest
thing he could have done in response
winston churchill called selassie out of
retirement gave him the codename mr
strong and flew him secretly to khartoum
with a simple goal train up an army of
resistance invade italy's colonies and
kick mussolini out on his pudgy ass it
was a plan the king of kings would carry
out with extreme prejudice
[Music]
when selassie fled the oncoming storm in
1936 he'd been attacked for abandoning
the people the great coward is how
firebrand jamaican activist marcus
garvey referred to him but there was
nothing cowardly about the emperor's
return with ethiopia now recognized as
one of the allies the army of resistance
marched on mussolini's empire in january
1941 from a brutal occupying force the
italians became mere paper soldiers
crumpling up and blowing away in the
face of serious opposition on may 5th
exactly five years after addis ababa
befell italian control of ethiopia
collapsed that day haile selassie
re-entered the capital in an alfa romeo
as the emperor stepped out onto the hot
streets he was greeted with a telegram
from churchill it is with deep pleasure
that the british nation and empire have
learned of your imperial majesty's
welcome home
not that a free ethiopia was immediately
re-established for the rest of 1941 the
country was under british administration
there's some speculation london
considered remaining in control longer
but selassie was impatient to
re-establish his authority in january
1942 the british officially recognized
and independent ethiopia not long after
selassie finally did what international
supporters had been hoping he'd do for
years he fully abolished slavery a
long-standing form of punishment slavery
had been so entrenched in the nation
that even nominally anti-slavery
emperors like melanic ii had owned
hundreds of slaves even selassie himself
is thought to have been a slave owner
nonetheless it was by his decree that
the practice was finally ended part of a
second wave of modernization planned for
his nation but first the emperor wanted
that nation to expand for decades
ethiopia's north had been cut off from
the ocean by the italian colony of
eritrea with italy now defeated selassie
approached president roosevelt in
february 1945 with a request the
territory be handed to him after the war
at first uncle sam simply promised to
think about it but as the hot war ended
and the cold war began it became clear
that an american-friendly port on the
red sea could be
extremely darn useful in 1949 a joint un
allied powers report declared eritrea
was incapable of sustaining itself as an
independent nation three years later it
was joined in a federation with ethiopia
selassie's first major geopolitical win
in this new world order and this was an
order the emperor wholeheartedly
embraced despite his disappointments
with his forerunner selassie took
ethiopia into the united nations even
sending troops to help during the korean
war at the same time his restored nation
was plugging itself into world markets
inviting in western teachers to educate
the populace the rise of this dynamic
new ethiopia culminated in 1955 with a
brand new transformative constitution
for the first time an educated lower
house would be formed with law-making
powers the judiciary would be
independent the bureaucracy overhauled
and made to serve the people the
franchise was extended to every citizen
for the first time citizens rights were
codified yet for all of its progressive
sounding clauses the 1955 constitution
didn't create a democratic utopia buried
amid the text but permeating every line
were sections designed to do nothing but
shore up selassie's power to make sure
no one could so much as question him
selassie wanted a bright shiny new
future for ethiopia all right but only
if he was eternally at its very top it
would be this ambition that would turn
the final act of his remarkable life
into such an avoidable tragedy
so far in this video we focused on the
story of haile selassie the man the
mortal human who became ethiopia's
emperor but there's another story
playing out there in the background
taking place at roughly the same time
the story of how hailey selassie came to
be revered as a god unlike our main
story this version of selassie's tale
begins in 1916 when marcus garvey
announced to his followers look to
africa for the crowning of a black king
he shall be the redeemer at the time of
course africa was mostly a patchwork of
european colonies a truly independent
black king wasn't something that came
along very often at all so when haile
selassie was crowned at a grand ceremony
in 1930 it felt many among jamaica's
poor and disenfranchised the garvey's
prophecy had come true over the
following years the religious teaching
that selassie was incarnate began to
spread over the island taking its name
from his old title and birth name
rastafarianism would become one of the
caribbean's great social movements a
movement turbo charged by the italian
invasion playing into rastafarian
concepts about babylon in this case
colonial society oppressing black people
the invasion became a rallying cry when
zelassi retook the throne it only
confirmed that he was the prophesized
black messiah this elevation in rasta
thought soon got caught up in other
cultural currents swirling through
jamaica after denouncing selassie as a
coward garvey changed his mind and
started making ethiopia a focal point of
his back to africa movement this in turn
influenced drastifaris until selassie's
kingdom came to be seen as the promised
land of xan it probably helped that
after world war ii selassie had
established a land grant around chasmane
village that black people from the
americas could settle in initially
intended for those from the usa it soon
became a focal point of a minor wave of
rastafari immigration finally in 1966
the emperor made a state visit to
jamaica touching down in kingston on
april the 21st so many rasters swarmed
the airport that they took over the
runway turning a working transport hub
into an impromptu religious carnival for
rastafarians selassie's arrival in
jamaica was effectively his second
coming to this day april the 21st is
still celebrated as ground nation day
the day jah walked among the ordinary
man of kingston yet even as rastafarians
abroad were deifying him back home
selassie's reign was beginning to lose
its shine the trouble was all those
young elites alaska had encouraged into
his new schools were now adults adults
with enough education to question why
they were still ruled by an autocrat it
didn't help that selassie responded to a
failed coup by forming a new government
composed of the aristocracy and military
elites the impression was of an emperor
no longer taking his nation forward but
rather
holding it back especially when you
looked to eritrea in 1962 ethiopia had
dissolved its federation with its
northern neighbor in favor of outright
annexation this had led to an insurgency
erupting that tied up the army and
brought in a constant flood of bad news
it was about to get even worse as the
1960s rolled on other ethnicities within
ethiopia's patchwork of peoples would
begin to stage their own revolts he may
have just been recognized as the living
incarnation of god but the mortal man
who was highly selassie would soon have
a much bigger problem making sure that
living was exactly what he continued to
do
[Music]
by the close of the 1960s it was clear
ethiopia was in trouble in the cities
socialist inspired students were
agitating for land reform as their
leninist doctrine spread so did the idea
that ethnicities should have the right
to secede a right many disaffected
groups eagerly grasped soon uprisings
were springing up alongside the conflict
in eritrea gergium erupted as did sadamo
and degray but it was in wallow that the
match would be lit on the pile of
resentful dynamite now underlying
society in 1971 a terrible drought
struck ethiopia laying waste to the
countryside that year food stocks had to
be eaten to supplement the terrible
harvest when drought again hit the
following year even the seeds and the
grain was consumed all of this led to an
inevitable and horrific outcome in 1973
famine today it's unknown exactly how
many died in the wallow famine although
estimates place it as around 200 000
people but the real problem was
selassie's reaction rather than beg the
international community for help the
emperor tried to hide what was happening
even throwing sumptuous banquets to
cover up the food scarcity so when the
news finally broke it made the emperor
not just look callous but actively cruel
and that tipped the scales from we need
reform two
that all has to go in june 1974
following six months of strikes rioting
chaos a bunch of military officials and
self-proclaimed socialists formed a
committee known as the durg on september
12th they overthrew selassie in a coup
dragging him from his palace as crowds
jeered and shouted insults initially the
dirk wanted to play selassie's son on
the throne but when crown prince asked
for wasps and refused to go along with
them the derg were all like all right
fine i guess we'll just rule by
ourselves then the announcement of a
communist state on december 20th
effectively ended the ethiopian monarchy
after 3 000 years in its place came a
military hunter that would take ethiopia
into a series of wars and famine far
more terrible than anything that
happened on selassie's watch but the
last emperor wouldn't be around to see
it on august 27 1975 the dirk pursley
announced that selassie had died of
natural causes while that's not
impossible for a man of 83 many still
believe he was murdered especially given
his final resting place after the fall
of the derg in 1992 selassie's bones
were found entombed in concrete beneath
the private toilet of the durg's leader
colonel mengistu it would take until
november 2000 for his relatives to
finally receive an official re-burial
today as when the emperor was alive
there exist two hailey selassies one is
the selassie of raster thought a black
spiritual leader that a million people
worship and millions more have heard
about this selassie is an icon not just
for his role in rastafarianism but for
being a powerful african leader at a
time when most of africa was subjugated
but there's also another selassi one who
started out as a reformer only to wind
up being consumed by his inability to
reform as fast as his people needed this
selassie is all too human a remarkable
man but still just a man and one who
sadly ended his reign not beloved but
driven from power whichever selassie you
believe in though there's no doubting
his historical significance as the last
emperor of ethiopia selassie guided one
of africa's most important countries
through an era of bloodshed and change
that effectively turned a medieval
society into a modern state he may not
have been perfect his improvements may
have been broadly undone by the durg's
bloody rule but he still was a
transformative leader one whose name
will echo throughout history
[Music]
you